Our next speaker is uh Jenny Ller from
Penn State.
Okay. Thank you, Joe. Um my topic today
is on sustainable dairy cropping systems
and we call this the virtual dairy farm
and you'll see that in a few minutes why
it's called that. Um I just want to um
recognize Heather Karsten who's a
professor at Penn State who is leading
this project which was funded through um
Northeast S. Uh Glennon Malcolm is the
postoc who handles the day-to-day
activities of this project and Tim Beck
is a uh farm management educator that we
work with and Jill was talking this
morning about you wanted more economic
information. So I'll be giving you some
economics here.
um this project um is very
interdisciplinary
and there must be 25 plus faculty and
staff that are on this project and that
doesn't include all the graduate
students. Um so so this is a huge
project and um we're looking at
developing sustainable dairy cropping
systems and monitoring multiple
indicators of systems performance. And I
just have some pictures down here below
that we're looking at uh red clover as a
green manure. We've got cover crops.
We've got um integrated pest management.
We've got alalfa. So there's a whole lot
to this project that we're just touching
the tip of the iceberg. Um, but what I'm
presenting on today is that we're
comparing two very diverse cropping
approaches. And what I'm looking at is
the impact on feed inventory, feed
quality, and economics.
And so what I'm going to be presenting
today is we're going to be comparing two
scenarios. Um, so the one I'm going to
be referring to is the best um,
management practice, but then we also
have a best management practice
enhanced. So the best management and
best management enhance they both have
similar practices which is cover and
green manure crops.
They both have alalfa and alalfa orchard
grass mix has integrated pest
management. And one thing that's very
novel for us in Pennsylvania is we're
growing canola for both the feed and the
fuel. Now in the enhanced um practice
we're also incorporating small grains
for silage. We are only growing alalfa
and an or orchard grass mix. In this
particular scenario, we are using
reduced herbicide where in the other
practice we're using standard herbicide
and in the enhanced we're using manure
injection versus in the um just the
regular best management we're doing um
surface or broadcast um application of
manure. And so that's how I'm going to
be identifying the two practices here as
we look at some of the comparisons.
Uh this is a picture of our aronomy farm
at Penn State and the goal is here to
produce the forage feed and fuel for a
65 lactating cow. And I know probably
out in this area that's seems pretty
small but in Pennsylvania the average
herd size is about 60 65 cows and this
is on 240 acre. Um and we're trying to
minimize offfarmm inputs. So at at the
aronomy farm, we're growing these crops
at 120th the size, but we're still using
farm scale equipment.
And so when we scale this up on our 240
acre farm, we have 100 acres that are
committed to the alphalfpha mixtures. We
have 40 acres to corn silage. And then
our grain co crops, we have 20 um for
corn, grains, soybeans, and wheat, which
the wheat is we're using for the straw
or the bedding component. and we have 40
acres that are in canola. And then we
have cover crops which are rye and red
clover. And so what we're taking from
from this is we're looking at the crop
yields and we're looking at the quality.
And I know in some of the sessions today
there's been um and yesterday we're
talking about models. Well, as Dan
mentioned, one of my roles is managing
the um university dairy. And so not only
do I use the model, but our dairy herd
is getting fed a ration very similar to
what we're doing here in the virtual
farm. So what I'm doing here is that
when the when dairy herd goes up in
production, our virtual farm probably
does. When they go down because of
temperature, heat stress, our virtual
farm goes down. So I am using a real
life herd to um mimic what we're doing
here for our virtual farm.
So, um, our dairy herd, here's what it
looks like. And I want to emphasize this
is a startup dairy. Um, this created
some challenge when we're starting this
project because if we were to assume we
were established farm, we would have to
make a whole lot of assumptions about
how much previous inventory we would
have. And to me, that seemed like it was
going to muddy the waters a lot. And in
Pennsylvania, we do have farms that do
start up this way. So, this is not
unrealistic. And this way, we're we're
starting with a clean slate. Um, so we
have 65 milking cows and they're
averaging about 34 kilos. But we have
the other animals on the farm that we
have to take into account. So we have
the dry cows and we have all the heers.
And this herd officially started its
rations on November 1st um, 2010.
And in this scenario, we are in a tie
stall barn. And here's a picture for
those of you that may not have seen what
a tie stall stall barn looks like. And
in this farm, we do feed a total
extraction to the lactating cows. And we
have the dry cows and heers, which get a
partial TMR, which means that usually we
have some additional forages that that
are fed outside of the TMR. And we have
five upright silos. Now, from when doing
this from the economic standpoint, um,
Timbeck, the farm management, so we've
taken into account that we've had to
take out loans to, um, because we
already had some of these facilities in
place, but we had to upgrade them. So,
we actually have the um financial part
of it using FINAC that takes into
account that this farm has had to take
out loans, there's capital purchases or
all of that. So we have a pretty
complicated intensive um economic part
that's taking into account um what this
farm would have to do if it was starting
up. And we are taking into account that
we are um accounting for losses during
storage and feed out.
Um our rations which are similar to what
we're feeding at the Penn State herd.
We're feeding at 65% forgebased ration
35% concentrate heavy forage rations for
the dried cows and peppers. And we're
using the models to formulate for
metabolizable protein, which is what
we're also doing at Penn State. So our
our protein in the ration is between 15
and 16% in the diet.
So I'm going to share with you some of
the information now that we have three
years worth of data. And so this is a
summary inventory of the best management
practice and the best management
practice enhanced. And here for corn
silage, um 2010 we had very good yields.
We had very good weather. um we average
I think it came to about 19 tons to the
acre which was very typical for farms in
Pennsylvania during that year. However,
you can see what happened in 2011 and
2012. We are feeling the drought. We're
feeling some of this weird weather that
we've experienced in Pennsylvania and
that has started to reflect in what
we've been getting in our inventory um
for 2011 and 2012.
Then if we look at our hay crop forage,
um, keep in mind that in 2010,
primarily everything was a new seeding.
So when we're looking at our alpha alpha
and our alpha alpha grass mixtures, we
had very low yields that first year
because we were only probably getting
either one or two cutings off of it. um
2011.
As far as moisture content, we did very
well at getting um multiple cutings off
of our alpha alpha and alpha alpha grass
mixtures. However, in 2012, we had a
very unusual spring. It got very warm.
Yes.
Yeah. Could you tell me what the units
are talking about?
We're talking about tons.
Tons.
Yes.
Dry or wet?
No, this is wet.
Sorry about that. I missed that. Um
yeah, we're talking asphed times.
Um and you can see in our um best
management practice enhanced um in 2012,
we took a a big drop in in inventory
because of the type of weather that we
had. So this had was very detrimental
and this was something that our farms in
Pennsylvania dealt with. So what we had
to do here um when I have a hay crop
forge plus annuals, we had to do what a
lot of producers had to do. We had to
incorporate small grain and we had to
incorporate sorghum sudan. We had to
look at alternative forages because from
the farm standpoint of what I needed to
feed the cows, we were going to come up
very short.
And you can see that um in here in the
enhanced we had small brains which
boosted our inventory. And you can see
how the additional especially here in
our enhance with um moving that from 589
tons with the sorghum sedan boosted that
up to 983 tons. This is part of the
story that we're trying to get to our
producers that you've got to be
flexible. you've got to be able to, you
know, know what you're feeding and make
decisions to sort of um compensate for
some of the the weather issues that
we're dealing with, which goes with the
climate change that we were talking
about yesterday, is this is a real
effect that we're dealing with.
And then the next is to look at the
quality of some of the um ingredients
that we're harvesting. And and I'm
sharing here um some of the challenges
that we had early on with the canola and
the soybeans. Um, under the canola meal,
the typical is what we would be for the
solvent extracted. Um, 40.8% protein, 4%
fat.
But what when we're harvesting the
canola, we're doing mechanical
extraction. And if you look at 2010, we
had very low protein and we had a very
high fat content in the canola. And what
we found out is that the moisture
content was too high and we didn't do a
good job of extracting the oil out. Um,
then in 2011 and 2012, uh, we did a much
better job and we're seem to be staying
around at this 11 12% fat. Ideally, from
a nutritionist, I'd like to see if we
could get that lower, but we do seem to,
um, be doing a little bit better
with our soybeans. Um, this is typical
for us in the box, 41.8. 8% protein, 18%
fat. Um, the first year in 2010, we
found out that we were short on pod ash.
And so that had a uh negative effect on
the protein and also on the fat content.
So that was corrected. And you can see
now in 2011 and 2012 um our analysis is
looking very um close to what we would
typically expect for soybeans.
If you look at our corn silage analyses
and um I just picked this out because
most of us um work with corn silage but
for any of the forages um we have not
seen any differences between um the
strategies between um the broadcast
manure which is the best management
practice and the ejected manure which is
the enhanced and these analysis are very
typical of what we see at Penn State for
the corn silage that's harvest harvested
for the university herd.
So what the monthly events are that that
I'm responsible for is that I need to
formulate the diets for all the animal
groups. And so each month I'm tracking
the inventory um that we're feeding out
for the various animal groups. I
calculate the grain mix costs and I
track income over feed costs.
And so let me just um get you familiar
with this um graph a little bit. So
income over feed cost is taking the milk
income which is calculated from the milk
price and what the average milk
production is and we're subtracting off
the feed cost and this is on a per cow
per day basis. And so when you look at
the um far axis here the the numbers. So
when you see here in 2011 we got to a
high of $12. That means that's $12
income over feed cost after we paid all
the feed expenses for the lactating
cows. So that's how much money is left
over to pay all the other expenses on
the farm. And if any of you have been
familiar with the dairy industry, you
know that 2012 was not a very good year.
And that's reflected in the income over
fee cost. And and this is something that
we're trying to look at and track and
see how do these different cropping
strategies um how how do we weather the
storm during these low times.
So we have the blue which is the
enhanced best management practice and
the red is just the the um standard best
management practices. But we have seen
here during two times that the enhanced
practices has showed a slight advantage
in income over feed cost.
And the reason for this is one forge
quality. We had um weather challenges
with the alphalfpha grass silage quality
in the best management practice enhanced
scenario and I had to feed between 40 to
43% concentrate and heavier corn silage
in 2011. Now you're probably thinking,
well that doesn't make sense. You're
feeding more concentrate. You'd think
that that would be more expensive.
However, we're we're growing our own
corn. We're growing our own soybeans and
we're growing our own canola meal. And
when you take in the price of what we're
raising on farm and putting in here, it
actually was economically a little bit
more advantageous than um the regular
BMP strategy.
The other um scenario that came through
was the effect of forage inventory. We
had no carryover of corn silage for the
regular BMP scenario for fall of 2012
and we had to feed fresh corn silage.
And those of us that deal with nutrition
know that when you have to feed fresh
corn silage, you have a negative impact
on milk production. So we saw a negative
effect on milk production. However, in
our in enhanced scenario, we had a
two-month carryover of corn silage. So
we were able to maintain or increase
milk production. So we're seeing how the
inventory and quality are impacting um
sort of the economics of these different
farm scenarios.
Okay, this is giving you um a little bit
and this may be more economics than what
you want to be um digesting right now.
So, we're looking at the cost prices for
crops grown in 2010 on on the BMP
scenario and on the enhanced. So, if you
look over here in the far left,
every month I do a feed price list. And
so, these are this is the average market
price dollar per ton for 2011.
So, for example, corn silage for that
year averaged $33 a ton. And then you
can see what it actually cost us to
produce the forages in the different
scenarios, which we were pretty close.
This is not a good thing. Um, we should
be a lot lower, but um you're seeing
that our costs are pretty close to what
the market price is. Where you really
see the impact during our first year is
in the alpha alpha grass silage and the
alpha alpha hay because they were new
seedings. We had very limited cutings.
So the inputs are staying the same
whether you had two cutings or four to
five cutings. So that's why you're
seeing very high prices for um alpha
alpha um silage mixes whether as silage
or as hay.
But you can see what we did here on our
corn soy. Um what it cost us to produce
it was much lower than what it would be
if you had to pay for it um based on the
market. And because this was the first
time doing the canola, you can see that
our unit prices um were pretty high. But
we should know that this includes um the
canola takes into account not only the
meal but also the oil. So that's why we
have it's a little bit higher than what
you would have seen on the market.
The good news is now for the crops grown
in 2011 but were fed in 2012.
Here you can see what the difference in
the market prices for the various
forages. However, again looking at corn
silage, our cost to produce the corn
silage was a little bit less than
market. But we now we've had a
substantial impact on our hay crop
forages. What has cost us to raise it is
much lower than the market price. And
again, this is because we got four to
five cutings off of those crops. And
we're still doing a very good job as far
as what's it costing us to produce the
corn and the soybeans. And our price of
the canola meal has come down.
So the question that that people have
been asking is how does the virtual
dairy startup farm and I have to
emphasize startup compared to
established Pennsylvania dairy
operations and one of the things is we
work with Pennsylvania um dairy
producers and doing their cash flow
plans. So we we have this information
and so we're looking at the summary data
of the farms that we've worked with and
in 2011 the purchase fee cost per cow
was about uh $1,200 $1,300
compared to our um different scenarios
which are about half of that. So our
purchase feed cost on our scenarios are
are very very low. And you can see in
2012 when feed prices were high, we were
up to almost $1,500 per cal, but yet in
our two scenarios, we're still
maintaining about half of the purchased
feed cost.
Now, when you look at the break even
income over feed cost, and this is after
we're doing a complete complete cash
flow, so we're taking into the whole
fixed cost, operating expenses,
everything. Our farms in Pennsylvania
are having break even income over feed
costs around $7.50 50 up to $7.76
for 2011 and 2012. You can see for our
two scenarios, we're up around $10. This
is not very good. If this was an
established farm, they would be in a lot
of trouble. For a startup farm, this is
not unrealistic. The good news is that
from 2011 to 2012, we've come down. So,
we're moving in the right direction. And
we're looking at our BMP enhanced is
actually showing a slight advantage. And
now we're getting into an area that
we're becoming a little bit more
competitive. And I would say as we start
doing this project over multiple years,
we we will be more of an established
farm and not so much a startup farm.
So now going back to the graph that I
showed you earlier on income over feed
cost.
This is based off of using market prices
for homeraised feeds. The reason why we
do that is because the farms that we
work with, a lot of them do not know
what it costs them to produce feed. So
this way we can compare apples to apples
when we're comparing farms. But now I've
given you what the break even numbers
are for our farms. The blue is the BMP
enhanced. The red is are just our
general best management practices. But
you can see on the dotted line where our
break even is. So when we're above our
break even, we're making money. When
we're below the break even, we're losing
money. So, we're trying to say is that
we want to now here in 2012, a lot of
producers were not making any money.
They were losing it, but we want to make
getting this break even number. We want
to keep getting that down so that
there's more times than we're making um
profit.
However, when you look at the cost, so
this is taking into the cost to produce
our feeds. How did we do on our break
even? So, this is showing the dollars
above or below break even. We were above
our break even. So, even though our
break even number was $10, we were still
the first year 2011 were making 42 cents
on average per cow. Um, and our enhanced
$151 in 2012 for the regular BMP $1.72
and the enhanced $218. So it looks like
right now that our enhanced best
management practice is showing a slight
advantage in what we're making um per
pal.
So, in conclusion, um the value of this
project is evaluating the sustainability
of the practices over time. And I think
over time is what we really need to
emphasize because now we're starting to
to see the weather effects, how the
inventory and the quality is impacting
um the enterprise. In our economic
analysis, we're doing both the whole
farm system as well as the dairy
enterprise. In the one scenario, we may
have more additional feed that we can
sell, which is going to be a positive
for the um enterprise, but we also want
to see is the dairy able to be
sustainable on its own without
generating additional income. Um,
generating the canola meal in the
straight vegetable oil as a fuel source
is a novel concept and this project can
be scaled down to evaluate herds that
have a limited land base. Um the way
that this um project is set up, we can
go in and change numbers. So if we if we
had a 65 cow lactating herd on only 150
acres, we can put that in there and see
what the impact of our different
cropping strategies would have on that.
Um in the proceedings, um you have links
to the detailed information about this
project. Um one of the things that's
been very popular with the producers is
the impact of slugs. Um, slugs are a
major pest for us and have had I think
the slugs um and and some of the insects
that have affected our crops. That's
been one of the challenges here in in
these different cropping strategies. Um,
but yeah, there there's a lot more going
on than what I presented um here. So, if
you wanted to get more information about
the project, that's where you can find
it.
Thank you.